vous prenez la pilule non parce que mon
mari de forts maux mais autrement moi je
suis pour un tout à fait pourquoi vous
voulez pas que le train n'a pu la perdre
et blanc de l'autre ce qu'une femme qui
pour la fidl
je sais pas moi parce que sa tâche est
plus libre et plus du monde oui je
savais pas qu'elle se trompe oui oui de
tête ni celle des grands chemins et moi
je n'ai envie que j'ai pas qu'elle me
trompe pas ce que j'ai vu je connais pas
mal de femmes ou de filles qui prennent
la pilule et qui fait qu'ils sont libres
d'avoir des rapports que n'importe qui
de flirter avec n'importe qui vous allez
débattre à l'assemblée nationale d'un
projet de loi sur la contraception est
là et l'avortement et il n'y a
pratiquement que des hommes à
l'assemblée nationale vous trouvez ça
normal
je trouve abusif que ce soit une
assemblée d'hommes qui décide du sort
des femmes sur un problème comme celui